hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to when goats join cults I
have to enunciate that because my mouth
can't say it right but apparently this
goats wants to reject the social norms
that his family and friends taught him
and go off and join a cult unfortunately
me thinks that I'm waving my hands too
much unfortunately this is the type of
cult that probably eats and sacrifices
goats cuz there's a lot of those maybe
the cult but either way this goat is
steadfast you will stay true to his
course and he won't be DVD Drive
anyway this goat is gonna not make a
mistake and end up dead although he
probably is because seeing that there's
five endings to this game it's gonna
it's got to come Swift and and probably
horrifying in a lot of blood he'll
recruit today we see if you have what it
takes to join the corpulence thanks Bob
you oddly enough look like Bob except
that you're more balding so a mixture of
Bob and Wade before that though let me
give you a tour of our headquarters the
upper right is the armory your left is a
library opposite the library is the
initiation chamber oh right arrow you
should head there right now other room
other room what other room I don't know
what you're talking about unless you
mean oh oh the forbidden room oh that
little old thing oh don't you worry
about that you must not go there excuse
me a burp came out as word so the
initiation room was over here what is
with my guida what's what's with my
larynx why is why is my neck bulging out
precariously on Magoo also I love this
guy's little dancer he can't wait are
you still taking ern sit down at the
table and we'll get started
oh you're different oh you're Tim okay
thanks Tim hey you know something about
this tells me that this ain't gonna be
good as you know the corporates are a
cult of eaters about eating to prove you
belong you're gonna use the arrow keys
to eat as much as you can Oh Timmy Tim
Tim Tim Tim is that your box up there
Tim Oh Tim what's about this blood on
the
has this wine or minused on soup or
something else it's definitely not goat
blood oh well now that you said that I
feel so much safer and securer about
what we're doing here at the dip even
the go to the table just looks like oh
[ __ ] I know I'm gonna dive at least
they're gonna give me free food whatever
these possibly goat related food items
are now 800 left left right up up left
oh [ __ ] up oh no I'm gonna die fight oh
god I messing it up down down left up
left nothing I like more than seeing a
fat oh oh I suspected this right I
didn't think that it was gonna come in
this way I love to eat fat goats oh oh
god damn it that was a guillotine dumb
goats never learned as soon as they sit
down at the table they're tuned well ah
a shake of salt a twist of pepper garlic
and rosemary and of course roasts did
goat well
we're dead now so I guess that's the end
of this little adventure oh boy unlocked
ending number one
what other wonder what other horrible
horrible yeah hi Hershel hi hi Hershel
didn't mean to click on this I got I
gotta go Hershel okay hey Bob um I'm
gonna go I'm gonna try to see what's
like John okay I came to visit
ha ha beat your system I beat it
Oh get crushed dude you know I assumed
that there would be like a splat of
blood and maybe some guts everywhere but
it's kind of worse that he's just there
with a slightly flatter head oh boy
well I enjoyed my meal maybe I could eat
and then maybe I could eat can I still
eat aw but the free possibly goat food
who's that loud sound
ah Jim wanted to be one with the box
I'll investigate very soon okay so
library was to the left the armory was
up above so I I should probably get a
weapon hi
we love goat this is the most boring job
in the world
if only I had something to entertain me
hey don't start supposed to be in here
oh all right
everyone get in here uh he's come to my
attention that someone dropped a box on
Tim's head Tim are you okay
Oh Tim's a lie I'm thirsty for vengeance
he's fine everyone plays we're all
friends here whoever did this needs to
apologize in front of the group no
apologies can only mean one thing
oh oh oh it's so simple how did I not
see that from the beginning
oh I understand your logic now you are a
smart guy Bob fortunately we learned a
secret handshake for this exact
circumstance oh oh uh uh goat in our
mist uh
you don't know that just as I suspected
you didn't even try to blend in I
suppose I didn't expect much from an
animal that eats shoes and garbage hey
that's profiling that's racist how dare
you that's specious tonight corpulence
we eat the flesh of the mountain I mean
that sounds badass but in the end I
think you're still gonna rip my limbs
off and stuff me in your gullet
goat flesh that is in case you were
wondering I see I was right my
hypothesis has been proven you are naked
and stupid and so you were caught they
called you audacious they called you
bold in the end they stopped talking and
- eating oh you did not taste like
chicken no he tastes this is like goat
ah this game silly this games silly it's
a silly game
all right you are reborn goats have more
lives than cats
Oh
I don't know if that's banging her
murder I can I can't really tell the
difference there let me zoom in on that
yeah still not clear okay so excuse me
oh my dear Oh Mon Tiffin
ah the corpulence and the mont offends I
get it so does that make me Romeo or or
go do or
Juliet go go - yet I don't know my
wondrous corpulent they said we could
never be together
fortunately they never come to the
library
oh excuse my goodness here you certainly
are for what ah what your beard is white
and it smells like smells like haha
seracote in here what are they all blind
or maybe they are all blind ha ha there
it is yeah oh [ __ ] dude thanks man
take look sure you guys don't mind stop
biting me and feels like you're trying
to chew off my leg I'm not oh boy uh-uh
that's it but that means that can only
mean oh okay thanks alright you get back
to your whatever you're doing and yeah
I'm gonna go cuz I've do okay so I got a
look so what is the book mean hello oh
you would you like a book buck why
you've brought me a book how to tenderly
cook good hey it's by eye the words Oh
my favorite book I remember when my
mother used to read me how to tenderly
cook godinez when I was a young baby cuz
I remember being a baby
sounds like a good read okay good bye
I'm gonna steal
yes they'll never suspect me okay so now
do I talk to this okay so I don't know
the handshake but I kind of want to get
all the endings I bet I bet if I'm in
this uniform and I eat you won't cut my
head off because that would be super
weird if they did that to their
initiates but then he'd teach me the
handshake so I'm gonna kill him blam
she's so violent
all right what was that sound maybe I
could finish him off maybe go eat a bit
no no good have it about okay yep please
oh do the handshake uh only goats don't
know the secret handshake every other
living creature both living and dead in
the entire universe know it except [ __ ]
goats before logic dictates your goat
logic also dictates your date's
delicious
oh boy well so close for years the
corpulence told stories of you Jiminy
Cricket they would say he almost fooled
us laughter followed by a wisecrack
don't you mean jiminy goat you might
have found this funny if it bit but
you're dead you did you're eating your
your anus was cooked very tasty Lee if
that's any consolation
I mean when I die I hope that people say
for years what a tasty it is that
markiplier add why do I feel a lingering
sense of unease as if the bowels of the
underworld vomited forth the Prince of
Darkness himself the gout is back Oh
alrighty then how about another you have
such strong hands thank you so strong
don't make it weird
strong sexy dear God I don't want to
alarm you but the coat is poppin it
hooks into you back oh well let's
pretend I'm not turned on huh
are you are your teeth yellow and blue
pale sickly blue describing a goat mouth
no I'm describing the mouth of an angel
well I was just gripping the hands of
the [ __ ] jewel there's only one thing
to do then do you marvel Oh to mock this
goat want to stay here with us
let's get funky oh yeah oh yeah yes no
one expected to fall in love but
everyone did love came at the cost of
envy on the day they turned you in no
one dared to speak but afterwards after
you had been cooked afterwards
they wept oh that's actually sad so we
fell in love and then they then they
cook an eight cook cooked and ate my
anus we're gonna we're gonna go eat
we're gonna we're gonna eat a bit hey
buddy you want to get eaten or something
stop messing around on the table we used
to lurk go to their deaths
oh well uh ah well ah so somewhere here
is a handshake secret I think I think I
remember they did hand signals so it
might be that the hand signals are like
a clue to what it it should be if that's
not it I'm gonna have to think of
something else right about okay right up
up left okay right up up left
oh okay so here's what you do I had to
look this one up because it was a bit
convoluted so you see that thing on the
right that's not just wall that's a
ladder apparently I don't know why I
didn't notice that
but it's a bit nondescript and
everything's pixelated so that's my
excuse I'll take the ladder with me
wherever I shoved that into that's
perfectly acceptable okay what was that
loud sound I'll investigate very soon so
we have to take it before you go over
here and then you place it over there
this is forbidden room is off-limits to
impressions I'm God huh that's a new one
you're still not allowed upstairs good
bad I'm going goodbye oh well this ain't
good oh that oh that oh I've got to
learn the new secret handshake
what was it up left right down up left
right down yeah I think that was it okay
so I got a jump on the oh I got a I got
climb the ropes of a hung goats not that
sounds different but it's still just
like it's all bad there's no way to
recover from that I'll just move on up
left right down now that was definitely
it up left right down oh I'm going to be
100% honest here I don't remember the
handshake oh no that's too bad for you I
always knew I always knew you were a
goat what the guy next to me has horns
how dare you he was born that way
technically true he has a tail he was
also born with the tail also true and he
has silence tonight we shall feast on
the loins of a goat um
oh the Murphy's credit it took them an
hour to catch him but catch him they did
later nobody mentioned he did not taste
like goat also the fact no one knew what
to make of the newest recruit he who had
hooves for hands in the end the
corpulence accepted you
you lived among them and you died in
their arms then they ate you what are
they also cannibals or did they owe
because you were good okay so they
finally realized and the core pilots are
a goat eating Colts thank you for
stating the obvious and that is when
goats join cult so the lesson learned
here for when goats join cults is that
you shouldn't join the specific cult
that eats you cults in general seem to
be okay although they seem to rely on
quite a bit of cannibalism but you know
who can judge I mean to each their own
I mean spread your wings and fly
question mark I have no idea if that's
exactly what the lesson we should learn
here but I'm not a good lesson learner
in fact I rarely learn anything so thank
you everybody so much for watching
please expunge all the lessons that
you've learned out of your brain and
ooze them into a jar and store them away
in a dark dark place and bury them
forever just like gold your report and
thanks again for watching so and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]